[Musique]
le 6 manuelle bonjour bonjour vous êtes
la présidente de contact entreprises on
vous a invité pour parler des ateliers
de saint pierre parce que ça y est c'est
parti
ce jeudi soir ça va commencer donc que
ça va durer deux jours
cd est et le centre de découverte des
sciences de la terre à saint pierre
alors rappelez nous pourquoi vous avez
voulu organiser ces ateliers de saint
pierre en partenariat avec la
municipalité avec la ville nous avons
souhaité organiser des ateliers de
saint-pierre déjà parce que c'est un
format que contact entreprises organise
maintenant depuis quelques années nous
avions par le passé organiser les
ateliers du btp les ateliers canne sucre
rhum
et puis les ateliers de la mer avec la
volonté à chaque fois de de mettre en
lumière un atout un atout et un
potentiel effectivement de la martinique
et lors d'une visite terrain sur sur
saint pierre
nous nous sommes rendus compte
effectivement qu'il y avait un potentiel
dormant incroyable à saint pierre nous
avons redécouvert saint-pierre puisque
nous avions eu l'opportunité de faire
une visite terrain avec avec la mairie
effectivement saint pierre c'est ce
n'est pas que la catastrophe est souvent
on associe saint pierre la catastrophe
saint pierre c'est vraiment un musée à
ciel ouvert se sont c'est un
c'est un des épaves archéologiques dans
la bête
il ya vraiment un potentiel à explorer
et à exploiter à saint-pierre et c'est
pour ça que la question centrale de ces
ateliers
et si saint pierre était l'atout
touristique majeur de la martinique pour
une interrogation mais ça sous-entend
que st-pierre a le potentiel pour
devenir effectivement un des atouts
majeurs de touristique de l'île
exactement exactement et l'idée c'est
effectivement sous la forme d'un atelier
qui se déroulera demain donc avec quatre
tables rondes d'interroger et de
mutualiser la réflexion entre à la fois
des personnalités de la société civile
mais également des experts techniques
d'aidé des acteurs socioprofessionnels
de pouvoir réfléchir ensemble pour
concrètement sortir de cette journée
avec des pistes de solution concrète
pour valoriser les atouts touristiques
de saint pierre alors on va revenir sur
le déroulement donc sur ces deux jours
28 et 29 donc ce jeudi et demain
vendredi sur la tenue de ces ateliers
mais pour nourrir les réflexions qui
seront menées pour nourrir les échanges
qu'il y aura au cours de ces ateliers
sur deux jours vous avez donc lancé une
enquête en ligne
donc sur sur internet et vous avez
restituer donc avant-hier mardi les
résultats
alors d'abord sur le nombre de
participants un peu moins de 400 comment
vous jugez ça comment vous estimez ça on
est assez satisfait des retours puisque
effectivement on a réussi à toucher un
peu moins de 400 400 martiniquais c'est
un panel qui est tout à fait honorable
pour pouvoir utiliser les les réponses
et donc du coup faire en sorte que ces
réponses deviennent aussi alimenter la
réflexion de demain
nous avons eu effectivement les l'idée
était de pouvoir interroger la société
civile sur la façon dont est perçue
saint-pierre tant en termes d'atouts
touristiques de projection pour
saint-pierre et donc nous avons
effectivement eu des réponses
intéressantes
74% des personnes qui ont répondu à ce
sondage estiment que c'est une ville
touristique donc éminemment touristique
ce qui est intéressant également c'est
au niveau de la perception c'est que
pour pour 42% des personnes qui ont
répondu c'est le tourisme historique qui
doit prôner effectivement dans le
développement d'une approche stratégie
touristique pour saint pierre que ces
atouts sont 61% l'histoire de l'éruption
mais 52% également l'histoire et le
rayonnement de saint-pierre avant 1900
de 51% les ruines
donc en fait nous avons effectivement
des récoltes est un matériau très
intéressant qui va venir alimenter les
réflexions de demain alors en proportion
vous indiquer que 92% de ses presque 400
martiniquais ou personnes plus largement
qui ont répondu à ce questionnaire en
ligne 92 % des répondants réside en
martinique et 27 alors là c'est
intéressant effectivement 27 près de 2
28 % habitent à saint pierre
donc il ya quand même une majorité
pierrotin qui ont participé ce qui est
assez logique finalement
et puis pour le reste donc 18 ce vienne
habite fort de france parmi les
répondants à cette enquête en ligne
et puis ensuite les trois villes
suivantes donc c'est le lamantin
schoelcher et le carbet communes
voisines du de saint-pierre alors
dites-moi donc vous en tant que
représentants de chefs d'entreprise ce
partenariat avec la ville c'est quoi
c'est pour comment dirais-je donner plus
d'attractivité à cette ville fait
revenir les investisseurs parce que bon
voilà c'est pas de la philanthropie que
là vous faites non plus hein c'est quand
même dans une perspective
d'investissement de développement
économique à travers le tourisme mais
pas seulement de saint pierre oui puis
d'être activité vous l'avez
effectivement puisque nous sommes très
préoccupés par part par la crise
d'attractivité que connaît le territoire
allant même que nous avons de forts
potentiels et saint pierre saint pierre
est un des potentiels a développé l'idée
c'est qu'il est intéressant d'avoir le
regard des chefs d'entreprise des
socioprofessionnels parce que l'approché
très pragmatique et très concrète
comment concrètement pourrait-on
optimiser et développer valoriser
saint-pierre non non pas comme une ville
mais comme un atout touristique
martiniquais quelles sont les pistes
concrètes que l'on pourrait mettre en
avant pour effectivement atteindre cet
objectif de développement d'un atout
phare qu'est la quai saint pierre
donc on va venir à ces ateliers
donc ils vont tueur et qui vont durer
deux jours alors d'abord qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qui aura ce ce jeudi puisque
on le rappelle ce sont des ateliers
gratuits ouverts à tous
et donc il y aura des vous avez voulu
aussi réunir parce que cet aspect de
synergie des différents acteurs et
d'abord la population pyrrhotine
elle-même voulait l'impliquer en tout
cas c'est l'objectif que vous affichez
comment ça va se dérouler donc d'abord
aujourd'hui et puis ensuite ce qu'il y
aura demain vendredi à exactement ces
ateliers sont ouverts à tous pour avoir
effectivement à la fois de la société
civile est également les experts invités
ce soir nous aurons la conférence
inaugurale avec deux personnalités très
intéressante avec un regard croisé qui
sera très intéressant puisque on reçoit
une historienne marie chevreau lamothe
et puis nous recevons également un
essayiste et philosophe français michel
onfray
ce sera intéressant d'avoir aussi son
regard de personnes extérieures qui qui
est tombé amoureux de saint pierre et
qui a fait le choix le plus si extérieur
que ça finalement parce que il est
devenu résident administrés piroton
exactement et d'avoir son regard
effectivement sur saint-pierre donc que
nous aurons cette cette belle conférence
inaugurale ce soir et puis demain nous
allons rentrer dans le vif du sujet avec
d'abord là vous me posez la question
tout à l'heure avec la présentation des
résultats du sondage
une façon un peu plus globale et puis
nos quatre nos quatre ateliers nos
quatre thématiques qui seront donc
alimentés avec le regard d'expert le
regard on a des artistes aussi qu'ils
seront là des personnalités de la ville
mais également des acteurs socio
économiques
la première thématique c'est si saint
pierre s'affirmait comme l'une des
grandes villes d'art et de l'histoire de
france
la deuxième thématique csi saint pierre
est elle à pompéi de la caraïbe et là on
est clairement dans regardons comment
des exemples
deux catastrophes ont pu être
transformée et devenir des véritable
atout économique pour un pays
et puis l'atelier numéro 3 l'après midi
sera et si saint pierre redevenait une
ville de la mer et enfin et si st pierre
renée c'est grâce à l'action citoyenne
des martiniquais voilà le programme pour
demain des quatre ateliers de travail
voilà alors bon le temps imparti est
déjà dépassée je voulais vous interroger
sur les quelques propositions que
contact entreprises a fait avec d'autres
partenaires d'autres chambres
consulaires chambre de métiers etc
bon ce sera pour une autre occasion lui
si manuel présidente de contact
entreprises parce que donc c'est terminé
on le rappelle tout ça ça va donner lieu
comme les précédents ateliers à une
publication ensuite voilà exactement les
ateliers secondes voilà les ateliers
seront seront suivies d'un compte rendu
et surtout d'un petit livre pour
qu'effectivement ne se soit pas lettre
morte et qu'on puisse utiliser tout le
tout la réflexion qui sera menée elle
demain pour des rencontres futures
et puis pour agir et agir concrètement
merci merci donc finalement la consacrer
tout le temps de ce ca ou caddie aux
ateliers de saint pierre mais c'est
notre actualité donc voilà surtout la
vôtre à contacter l'entreprise et à la
ville de saint-pierre merci présidente
de contact entreprises lucie manuel
d'avoir participé à ce 5 à 10 bonne
journée à vous et à tous nos auditrices
et nos auditeurs merci
[Musique]